did you have any issues with family or
anything growing up that made you use
humor to calm things down it's no longer
a challenge to make my classmates less
of a challenge became can I make the
teachers laugh you are creative but
you've been able to figure out a way to
monetize comedy as well on YouTube
reading people what's gonna make this
person laugh and then delivering so
first of all JP I gotta tell you there's
about 10 people out there that late at
night if I'm trying to go to sleep and I
need a laugh I need something to watch
in a lab you are one of the guys on that
list you crack me up brother thank you
for coming out here it's good to have
you on the show Thank You Patrick for
having me and I'm both complimented and
insulted at the same time that I would
be one of the ten that you used to laugh
to go to sleep and then of course
insulted that I'm one that puts you to
sleep it's so happy to be here with you
today brother ok so I told him earlier I
said you have this sense of humor Yogi
Berra because he's like this entire time
we've been talking his level of sarcasm
hasn't stopped you been on stuff on the
moment you came in here
but every time I was like wait a minute
two seconds later that was a joke he
just joked I got a two seconds late let
me just give you a couple of the
episodes that he's done on YouTube if
meat eaters acted like vegans do you
even know how dangerous deer are when
you're driving your car if you don't
kill and eat deer first you basically
want people to get into car accidents
how to become gluten intolerant give
expert medical advice once you take your
gluten-free vows you'll need to have an
automatic understanding that every
medical condition is caused by gluten
depression it's always caused by gluten
obesity that's a hundred percent glue
and passive-aggressive relationship
techniques oh thank you for cleaning the
kitchen for once GP shares so much
gratitude with me through his snarky
comments and at the same time he shames
me a lot he is so good at directly
communicating his thoughts with me
witness directed Shane she deserves it
at what point did you know listen I'm
I'm witty I'm sarcastic I'm awkward I'm
weird
different but guess what that's Who I am
and I know you gave a talk on it with
TED talks and you said the best way to
be unique is not to be yourself it's to
be like everybody else so when did you
you know come to your own and kind of
figure out a way to say this is who I am
I started YouTube and it was probably at
least nine months into doing comedy
videos on YouTube that I started to
arrive into my own and like figure out
this is Who I am and it's not only okay
but it's awesome and I want to celebrate
it more and and let more of me out so
that you know the first nine months of
YouTube was like a feeling out process I
felt like a new born cult wobbly legs
didn't really know like what is my
sarcastic voice on camera I always knew
it in my personal life were you
uncomfortable at first were you like how
are people can embrace me was there a
little bit of that or not at all I
thought doing comedy videos would be a
terrible idea I thought it would be the
worst thing I could possibly do for my
business which up until four years ago
when I started doing comedy videos I was
doing emotional healing client coaching
for 13 years like life coaching and I
was thinking like yeah I shouldn't be
funny in the public because that would
discredit me were you funny doing that
or was it a serious business very
serious serious yeah like really working
with people healing their their pain
their trauma helping them step into
their personal power resolve their life
challenges from my point of view if we
can't trust that means we're gonna be
forever lonely and isolated not letting
anybody in in my personal life ever
since I was a child a sense of humor
being a comedian was always something
there in my personal life but in the
professional life I was
compartmentalizing and telling myself a
story like yeah I should be serious
that's it was that amazing and it's
amazing I believe that story for so long
but then just kind of like having an
itch that you got a scratch I kept
having these ideas to convey concepts
through the language of comedy so comedy
video ideas kept coming to me and
finally I said all right I still think
it's gonna be bad for business but
do it did somebody push you over the
edge like what somebody saying come on
do it JP no no is this isn't somebody
inspiring you to do it this is you woke
up when they said I'm doing this yeah
all an internal experience and internal
journey I'd like to use the word journey
because I think I will sound more
spiritual being ultra spiritual has
nothing to do with actually being
spiritual because no one even knows what
that actually is but when I put my first
comedy video out a couple magical things
happen first inside it was so creatively
satisfying I had never felt it before
Wow like something woke up in me that I
didn't know existed one first one it was
just so satisfying so fulfilling and
then the first one was also pretty
well-received so there was that
codependent encouragement from the
outside world that was actually helpful
in supportive of people viewing that and
then it also turned out to be the best
thing I could ever do for my business
where my one-on-one client coaching
which I was doing at the time my
schedule got busier than I could imagine
because what happened was people found
my comedy video then they'd search
deeper in my youtube channel which had
well over a hundred just sincere serious
life coaching videos and they're like
wow this goofy guy's for real is that on
the same channel or you had a separate
channel same channels the same Channel
and all my serious videos are still on
my youtube channel so if you dig deep
enough you'll find a lot of non funny
videos so they're not private you didn't
go private or unlisted director to find
started my youtube channel with a
sincere wife coaching videos probably
about five and a half years I got it so
for a year and a half you went and he
said I'm gonna test this out with me
being specifically spiritual you know
serious year and a half later I'm gonna
test out the comedy and see how this
does yeah
how are you I'm JP Sears I would like to
share with you 10 tips to ruin your life
so that you can be certain that your
life is going to be ruined the way you
want it to be they're not amazing
because for us we start a value team and
I think
first fifty or hundred episodes we did
was called two minutes with Pat the only
episode that was every two minutes was
the last episode everyone it was nine
minutes eight minutes 11 minutes so as
finally said Pat stop lying to us this
is not 2 minutes but Pat this is 9
minutes with patty 11 minutes with Pat
so we adjust it but you can't alarm I
think how much of it you think it is the
fact that you just said I'm gonna start
creating content and after creating
content you kind of said what about if
we pivot here and make adjustment there
was it kind of like that process that
you went through yourself very much so
and I would call the process Forrest
Gump in my way through it none of it was
it none of it has been a premeditated
plan of here's the vision here's where
we're going and this will be a great
entrepreneurial move so following my
heart following what feels passionate
and inspiring to me and I will do that
so it's kind of like Forrest Gump is
aware of his next step he's not aware of
where that step and then the next step
in the next hundred steps are gonna lead
him because Forrest Gump who and I think
all of us could use a little more
Forrest Gump archetype in our life he's
my hero because here's a guy who's so
intellectually ill-equipped that he
couldn't follow his head so he had no
choice but to follow his heart
well and he would do that things would
work out for him and of course in the
story becomes a war hero football star
ping pong sandbox Thor yeah we all want
to be a ping pong sir I was just playing
before the interview about practicing
because I'm trying to see if I have the
ability to go to the Olympics well it's
what we're all working towards rights
ping-pong stardom
that one's your birthday by the would
months your birthday April April 12th oh
I'm an Aryan April 12 while my dad's
April 10th and I hire April babies
interesting are you are you very
organized or no I would say I'm pretty
organized yeah and your your
perfectionist like you do the best work
if you want something to get done you
feel like no one's gonna do better than
I'm unfortunately a perfectionist I'm
trying to surrender some of that control
but yeah are you clean neat freak as
well or no like you like you wash your
hands you got to be clean all the time
I'm a neat disordered person I'm not
quite at the freak level so you got to
do what unmeet freaky you got to do one
on OCD type of thing that'd be fine and
I think perfectionism would
great video for you actually I should
just do videos on you like I'll just
follow you around Patrick like oh here's
a new dislocation say JP here's the
video
okay I'm dealing with this issue
mentally you got to do video I'm trying
to figure it out how do we figure out a
sarcastic way to address this and you'll
be my unqualified doctor which we can we
can you know ultra spiritual you know we
can do something about yeah you know
I've far as I'm aware I've never been
qualified as a doctor at least on paper
but Patrick I want you to know that deep
down inside I identify as a doctor and
if you do that's all that matters
absolutely so so doctor JP Sears thank
you does it help you that you where
ferragamo shoes every day like do you
like wearing ferragamo shoes and your
Armani suit is this was this kind of
intentional like ferragamo shoes is a
that's the first time I've ever heard
that word so I assume it's a very fancy
shoes like this do you have seriously
how many of them right now I have three
and I'm definitely batting low you know
I recently did was a raw vegan cooking
show video where I made raw vegan bat
cuisine and I don't want to ruin the the
plot for everybody but I'm gonna give
the plot away so spoiler alert sorry if
it ruins your life at the end of the
video because I raw bat made out of
eggplant I contracted rabies and you
know I want the full meat eating
experience eating as a vegan so it's
like okay a bat substitute of course I
got to get vegan or II got to get rabies
which is kind of like being a vegan only
veganism it's probably more deadly so by
the end of the video I'm covered in
ketchup that was my substitute blood it
so it ruined my fourth purple sure so
you only have three of these that is
there a specific brand you stick to
either next level
or American Apparel I feel bad that he
only has three can we buy like 20 of
them and just send it to him on us
medium medium medium medium extra medium
extra me makes my small muscles look
bigger one of the things that always
interest me I grew
in a very pressure type environment I
grew up in Iran war you know parents
divorce refugee camp all the stuff and
my Savior would to kind of keep things
level head it was humor right that was
at least for me to be able to do that
did you have any issues with family or
anything growing up that made you use
humor to calm things down did you ever
have yourself sure you know I know you
you grew up in with literal war around
you and I won't pretend to imagine what
that's like and at a metaphoric level I
think part of the human condition is we
all grow up with wars around us it might
be conflict at home between parents or
some parents not there so it's like what
is our war and my war again it nothing
compared to what you grew up with there
was always tension at home my parents
were splitting apart getting back
together scouting apart getting back
together
dad's over working and mom's upset about
it and dad moves out and you know mom's
in bed crying for you know weeks at a
time how do you at the stuff I did at
seven okay and and I think even before
that started I didn't know it at the
time but looking back it's like yeah
yeah I could feel it I think children
are very much in tune with energy they
may not know how to intellectually
report what's going on and what they're
feeling but kids feel I mean there's
there's no secrets
even if secrets are being kept and in
fields of psychology they're really
uncovering like yeah we're really
affected by secrets because the energy
is there so of course how I responded to
that how I compensated was through humor
so if I felt insignificant inside and I
certainly did for quite a bit of my
childhood I didn't want to feel that so
I would compensate by making people
laugh wow so I get to feel significant
like I feel like I matter to you because
I made you laugh that helps me escape
the reality of this feeling of feeling
insignificant and then you know when you
do that thousands and thousands of times
you kind of get that Malcolm Gladwell
10,000 hours of practice of reading
people what's going to
this person laughs and then delivering
what's gonna make them laugh in an
effective way to make them laugh be it's
a very desperate way of getting
emotional needs met starts sharpening
the the satirical sword of humor
how early was that at 7:00 like did you
use your humor at 7:00 I was always one
of the class clowns yeah and and I
having a hard time believing that bother
with a class clown you know I just can't
see it right now obviously you know
you're having fun you're making
everybody laugh have you teacher likes
you sometimes they don't like you you're
probably that guy in school right for
sure and I found one you know once I got
to junior high and then high school you
need a you need a bigger challenge it's
no longer a challenge to make my
classmates less so the challenge became
can I make the teachers laugh push them
far enough to make them laugh without
pushing so far that you get in trouble
there's a fine line there you got you
know humorous tension and of course
creating tension is also what creates
trouble so of course sometimes I'd cross
the line and other times I'd get the
teacher to laugh and and that was very
joyful I don't want to discount the fact
that the humor to escape pain was also
creating joy so there's that white side
of it as well it's not just all dark
shadows did your parents stay together
or no they didn't yeah they did stay
together together and in fact just last
week I was doing comedy shows in Buffalo
New York and they came to my shows get
out of here yeah so is he still an
atheist and she's still a Catholic
Gordon yeah so doesn't change yeah it's
so funny like my mom she's never been
more Catholic she's going to church
every multiple times a week sometimes
you know like when it's her turn in the
rotation to serve coffee at church she
pulls my dad along and you know he's
there thinking this is all a bunch of BS
and but doing it to make my mom is
hilarious I love that school my parents
do one was a communist one was an
imperialist and they fought all the time
24/7 so for us were human but they
didn't stay together because if they did
World War three would have started but I
can only imagine if they were still
together and she's going to a communist
rally
honey I just can't see it taking place
do your parents also sport the purple
shirts like do you get him a purple
sheren-san mom can you wear this dad can
you wear this I've definitely gotten
them purple shirts especially when it's
my line of apparel and it's
disappointing how an often they wear
them something funny when my dad did
have a purple shirt on probably a few
years ago when my comedy videos were
first coming out and at the time in all
the videos I would have a headband on
flower in my hair
I still do that once in a while but it's
not every time things so I fly home and
I'm at the airport baggage claim my
parents are gonna be picking me up I'm
looking around like they're they're
nowhere around they said they were going
to be in baggage claim after a couple
minutes I'm scanning the room again and
then here's this doofus dressed in a
purple shirt long hair headband on
flower in his hair Hama is my dad where
no man can dress like it was hilarious
so they're proud they're excited to see
this becoming a reality they really are
in and it feels good everything I'm
doing I'm doing out of devotion to my
truth and my creative muse
when I'm a kid I think a lot of people
it's let's perform good let's get good
grades perform good in sports to make
mom and dad proud but I think approval
is a very cheap currency I think it
makes us go bad what parents even with
parents I mean you get approval and it
feels awesome for five minutes and then
you're bankrupt and then before too long
okay I got to do something more and then
before too long we're giving away
ourselves were being who we think our
parents want us to these then in order
to get approval so we bankrupt by true
self and we do that with parents society
friends right and and I think the the
real valuable currency sort of like the
inner version of Bitcoin if you will is
self acceptance I think when we're true
to ourselves when we're voicing our
voice and being true to the creative
Muse following our heart man that is a
very very valuable currency that's what
creates fulfillment not bankruptcy
Healing you know coaching
Bend unas 1213 years and all of a sudden
you have the start I want to go comedy
I've already done 100 videos what if I
make my next video comedy that's kind
that's very scary thing to do because
you're completely changing your brand
when you made that shift did one of your
businesses take a hit for like three
months like did the spiritual healing
business take a hit for a few months
until this one recovered and came back
up there was a big shift but there
wasn't a hit in fact it was sort of the
opposite where the online comedy videos
brought so much exposure you know people
come to my youtube channel dig deeper to
find my sincere videos from there like
well this guy's doing some real-life
cochise stuff here then they find my
website like oh he does coaching via
Skype or phone and so my schedule became
more full than what I could handle with
one-on-one clients so great problem to
have and then it's like okay I'm busier
than ever and I'm at the time making
comedy videos anywhere from once every
couple weeks to once a month I wasn't
really in my rhythm yet and then after
about nine months of doing comedy videos
when I want client coaching never been
more full I said I need more creative
space here so at the time is very scary
but I eliminated one day a week of doing
client coaching so I went from five days
a week to four days a week because it's
like I need time to do videos there's
something here how many times at this
point are you creating comment probably
on average once every two weeks for the
the spirit that comedy okay and then for
the sincere spiritual life coaching
videos those were about once a week okay
so I understand consistent with those
but it was scary like Wow one day a week
of income I'm gonna let that is so
irresponsible how did you manage that
yeah I felt the fear something that I've
learned from my own experience and then
I look at other successful people and I
guarantee you have stories like this
probably a wealthy library of them one
of the best keys to success is a
willingness to do the things that scare
you rather than avoiding the things that
scare you because that means we're
really avoiding
feeling the fear which means we're gonna
avoid the source of fear which is doing
something new that scares us I think a
willingness to do something that scares
you means you have to be willing to be
afraid I think the true warrior the true
courageous warrior is he or she who's
willing to be afraid and take action
anyway I think false courage is the
illusion of like oh they're doing stuff
and they're never afraid it's like no
that's not courage there's no courage if
there's no fear sure you're just doing
something that's already familiar to you
it's not challenging it's not new so it
was a new phenomenon took a lot of
courage and a willingness to be afraid
like I'm losing income but it felt like
there was something there I couldn't see
where I was going I couldn't see what
was coming towards me but it felt
purposeful and and then I went to you
know three days a week doing life
coaching in it at that time like now I'm
earning some YouTube revenue now there's
the occasional sponsorship now there's
the occasional speaking when is now is
now two years ago is now three years ago
was it a year ago now is three years ago
so three years ago you could essentially
say I'm dropping the coaching to do this
but you didn't yet right I was dropping
it gradually got a drop a day from the
week right now oh nine months later now
I'm dropping another day to fully drop
everything what it's just it wasn't
YouTube thing beginning of January 2017
year and a half ago yeah and in it it
was well past time I was making more
money than ever doing speaking
endorsements and it was just like yeah
that the coaching that served me so well
and it's such great rewarding work yet
the the call of my heart is taking me
elsewhere so I finally had to let it go
at your so January 2017 had you already
met your wife or not yet
I was in Costa Rica at a retreat I was a
guest teacher at a retreat I was
teaching something on emotional healing
and humor and during that retreat my now
wife was
also a guest teacher so I met her there
and it was on a hike during the retreat
I was talking to someone he's just a
big-time coach very wise dude and it was
while I was talking to him on that same
retreat where I met my wife where he
pointed out to me JP your energy drops
when you're talking about your coaching
but when you're talking about videos
when you talk about speaking
endorsements interest your energy
elevates and he said JP when are you
gonna drop this when are you gonna
finally drop the coaching and I said
you're right thank you for reflecting
that like so this is a mentor telling
you yeah it was at the retreat just made
the decision god I'm not doing any more
and that I'm sure I shared that with her
have you seen a movie a couples retreat
Vince Vaughn yeah will you that kind of
a speaker when you go there are you or
you like the guy do yoga goddesses come
on doing power I really I wish I was so
crazy you know you're speedo and you're
like this yoga instructor you just come
out of the water you do your hair ten
things like this that would definitely
be funny if we had a scene of you doing
that I think it's appropriate by the way
if you do make something like that as a
couple's retreat you should go into the
entertainment business
I should be an interesting thing about
that I should consider it you've got 2.2
million fans on Facebook you're at six
hundred and ninety thousand subs on
YouTube if you haven't seen this stuff
it's funny you got your Instagram 150
thousand something followers you're
doing some stuff with Twitter your
brand's being build up a lot of people
out there may be watching the same look
I feel like I'm funny you know I feel
like like even Kevin Hart once said I
didn't know if I could be a comedian
until one day at a swim graduation thing
there was 60 kids in the room and he
made everybody laugh and all the parents
came and said you should be a comedian
anyone I became a comedian I figured
that one out he's got a hundred fifty
million followers today made 69 million
last year what would you say to somebody
that's watching the saying you know what
I think I'm funny but I got an older
sister that makes fun of me being funny
or I got an older brother that makes fun
of me I've got a younger brother I got a
cousin I got a guy in school that makes
fun I mean my mom and dad make fun I
don't know if I'm really a comedian I'm
afraid what people gonna think but I
want to try it out you know maybe I can
do something with my comedy what would
your advice or counsel be to somebody
like that voice your voice
don't wait for validation don't wait for
some magical fairy to show up and say
it's time no the insecurity of not
knowing or the insecurity of like yeah I
really want to do comedy but what if
nobody likes it or that insecurity is
the part that's how greatness starts
Michael Jordan started off insecure he
was cut from the basketball team when he
was a sophomore in high school
insecurity is a necessary challenge it's
a necessary dragon to slay so however
you want to do it that might be start
going to open mikes it might be let's
make some sketches on youtube and put
them out there how do you do that how do
you make sketches on YouTube yeah maybe
give the system what is the system to
make some sketches on I think a great
way to do it is start with an idea start
making notes like get your computer out
or your phone make notes to develop the
idea like okay what's the what's the bit
here are we
portraying something that's going on in
society are you illustrating a pain that
happens in your life that other people
can relate to in a fun way
so write your script out then get a
camera on a tripod all my youtube videos
it's just a camera on a tripod I do it
all myself and when I made my first
youtube video after I filmed that I'm
like okay I don't know what to do next
so I went on YouTube and YouTube how to
edit video on iMovie so you edited
yourself on iMovie absolutely kidding
and then after I edit it on iMovie then
i YouTubed how to upload a video to
youtube so that's what you got to do
it's it's so easy amazing how simple it
is after you put the video out there put
on Facebook YouTube just all the places
don't worry what other people are saying
that's big by the way the first I don't
know how many people create content
after first video they stop for sure
it's like what if a bunch of people
watching they hate it and then the only
thing worse is well what if nobody
watches it yeah amuse thyself especially
with comedy amused thyself is the number
one commandment do it in a way where
you're so amused that it's worth doing
even if no one watches it that's the key
to sustainability
right because now you're gonna make
another video you got to be consistent
because especially with comedy there's a
lot of junk that needs to be worked
through not nowhere near all my videos
go viral it's like yeah there's some
videos I put out those look mediocre at
best but then if I don't put those out
if I'm not in the amuse myself mode then
the gems never see the light of day so
put out a video and keep going don't
worry what other people are thinking you
will worry what other people are
thinking even though I say but don't let
that stop you be the courageous warrior
who says yeah that's scary what other
people are thinking that's scary they're
gonna they will judge you and do it
anyway so so that's the creative side
that's that's the right brain style now
let's talk the left brain side you are
creative but you've been able to figure
out a way to monetize comedy as well on
YouTube how do you do that how did you
start doing that it's very hard to
monetize anything if you don't have the
audience built so I put at least 80% of
the weight in valuable content and I
know it's valuable if it amuses myself
by the way Patrick I just said your name
so you'll like me more it's part of
building rapport supposed to be yeah or
is the French say rapport I think
something that worked well for me in the
beginning to build the audience was I
was not worried about monetizing I was
always in the back of my mind like if
this keeps growing like yeah I'll figure
out my monetize it anyways because
you'll we're already making an income so
one don't drop your day job to be a
professional content creator yeah that
helped me build my audience it's like
yeah I'm gonna be true to the art here
not that you're untrue if you're
monetizing but I wanted all my energy to
go into the creative value content not
like creating monetization so once I was
off and running for a while then I
figured out hey let's do some
monetization so first thing was I'll
monetize the YouTube channel just
earning the the revenue from video ads
and then it was okay let me connect with
a t-shirt
Eponine do a little apparel line i sell
some of that and all things that were
fun to do and then then along the way
companies started approaching me which
is very easy monetization like JPY one
do a product placement or endorse our
product and and after a while I started
realizing I am spending more time
negotiating deals than I am creating in
fact I remember the summer of 2016 I hit
like a call it a little bit of a
rock-bottom burnout place where I was
burning the candle at both ends and in
the middle I woke up one day said it's
been over three weeks since I've put out
a video because I haven't had time and
that is pissing me off because I have
the creative urge right so it's like I'm
I'm killing what has created all these
opportunities so I needed new I needed
to do something and that was bringing on
a manager and and now with my manager
he's taking care of all the incoming
offers for sponsorships speaking
opportunities so I needed I think my
unique path was leveraging someone's
expertise so I can have more time doing
my art and he is better at negotiating
he's better at seeing good deals better
at sniffing out incongruent deals so
part of my monetization is having
essentially an expert manager how did
you find out how did you find a manager
at the time I had a lot of managers
reaching out to me okay so you were
already getting the attention in a
market place okay so you had choices I
had choices and it was overwhelming
because I had had choices for a while
but there's this like oh you know
there's so many whatever horror stories
out there people just wanting to use you
and there are managers agents I just
want to use you they'll talk a big game
but do they actually have the reciprocal
value to enhance you and your career so
I had taken a lot of phone calls with
managers and there was a producer who
wanted to talk to me about a potential
television
and start talking to them and it was
great and learning more about him he
manages a few select comedians and other
talent and I said well cool you know
we're talking about this TV stuff but
tell me the manager thing like I felt
trust with him tell me more about that
and like would you be willing to talk to
me about working together and he said JP
I don't work with many people I'm not
willing to do that I'm very selective
who I work with and I see big things for
you I love who you are what you're doing
I would be very willing to work with you
but I want you to talk to a lot of other
managers because if you decide you want
to work with me I want you to know it's
the right choice for you what a great
thing to say by the way for sure
phenomenal and all these other
conversations I were having were kind of
like pressurized JP work with me work
with Ron so yeah I took another couple
months talked to other managers but I
went back to him and I said Michael
let's go for it man and and he's been my
manager for over two years now and it's
just been an absolute dream so talking
to a lot of people while trusting my gut
instinct listen what a great store you
got man truly what a phenomenal story if
you're watching this if you want to
learn more about this man's video you
gotta go the channel is called what
awakened with JP awakened with JP
awakened with JP he's got that that
sound you put right off the bat it's
like that where is this yoga sound it's
a Tibetan vault starts up i like the
headband and i like the thing you would
put in your ear you doing that i was
kind of cool maybe you should sell a wig
like that and send it to me and i'll
take the wig and the headband and put
that flower in the purple shirt and post
a picture that you and i did something
together here again if you want to find
them whatever you took from this concept
this interview today send them a tweet
and again if you want to go watch this
content click on a link below in the
description section to go watch any of
the videos yes honest YouTube channel if
you like it
give them a sub as well and let them
know you found them here on value
tainment JP thanks for coming out buddy
really appreciate the time for sure
Patrick thank you for having me and I
what you're doing hey thank you so much